all units all units 1010 s at 36 and
park repeat all units be advised shots
fired in 50 hours
[Music]
yuria
I'm here what do you see by the rest
boss wasn't dead like the demons are
moving in on Fisk territory you got this
I got this
everybody is Charlie so so many of you
requested a spider-man ps4 video I
figured I'd do a breakdown in Easter
eggs for all this footage they dropped
they drove like nine minutes of gameplay
it is actually pretty cool there is a
spider-man giveaway that's going on
right now for the action figures for the
movie all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber leave a comment on this
video and it's actually pretty cool we
saw the trailer last year but there's a
whole bunch of stuff that you may have
spotted in this most notably Miles
Morales and gang ki at the end is sort
of an easter egg implying that they'll
be playable characters eventually in the
game so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to try to avoid talking over the
characters talking in the game so I'll
just drop the audio whenever they start
the cinematics but the early part here
where he's talking about the demons he's
talking about mr. negatives men this
trailer is hyping up mr. negative as one
of the villains one of the many villains
remember Arkham style all of Batman's
characters were in that game they're
teasing so many more things going on
here but mr. negative is just the early
boss of the game along with a Wilson
Fisk Easter Egg who is still stuck in
prison the really cool thing about this
is they says they took a lot of
inspiration from Marvel's Netflix series
and they also said they played a lot of
Batman Arkham which i think is funny
like yeah we're making a spider-man game
we're just going to spend a whole lot of
time playing Arkham game but as this
picks up you notice the costume looks
different from the homecoming costume in
the MCU he's supposed to be 23 in this
game he's been spider-man for several
years in the person he's talking to on
the other line the police Yuri is
actually Yuriko what Tana BAE who
becomes a wraith in the comics so pretty
much all the big characters in this or
big characters from spider-man comics
hey Willie
nice jumpsuit slimming stay out of my
business
wait the demons who's their leader keep
my men alive in maybe I'll tell
saving bad guys from other bad guy not
how I thought today would go the
interesting thing about this bite here
is that you take down mr. negatives men
it doesn't allow you to just chuck them
over the side of the building so great
power great responsibility there's a lot
of spider-man's morality dissipate into
the game plays you can't change so it's
not like spider-man's going to be
walking around dropping bodies on a dime
hey guys
it's a really cool fist your men are
safe your turn who runs the demons
you're about to find out check the roof
here
come on
oh no no
mr. negative his powers are actually
really interesting like during this
footage he tries to get him to chill out
he's like this is it you because you
don't know the real me mr. negative was
corrupted by the dark force so there's a
good part of his personality and there's
a bad part of his personality so when
spider-man is talking to Martin in this
footage he's trying to talk to the good
part of his person about a lot of these
acrobatics you'll see in the spider-man
homecoming movie you're not going to see
something this crazy though you have to
remember Tom Holland is only been
spider-man for a little while so he has
that big plane saved in the trailer
you'll see stuff like this when we get
to the second spider-man homecoming
movie the third movie when post Avengers
infinity war spider-man has his skills
raised up big time Yuri I got this you
see this Easter Egg for Osborn for mayor
so obviously green Goblin's in there
like I said Arkham style all of Batman's
rogues gallery or in those games all of
spider-man's characters are somewhere in
here but they haven't completely
revealed how you're going to run into
all them but mr. negative is not the big
boss of the game and neither is Wilson
Fisk when he's talking to spider-man in
this trailer so start laying your
theories for Big Bad now it could be a
member of the sinister six
it could be the jackal they were
actually teasing the jackal in the
future of the spider-man homecoming
franchise not for the current spider-man
movie but for the next one or even the
third one they're just a foreign
character that's going to show up during
the movie miles Warren is the jackal in
the comics
[Music]
okay flee here I come
hi is this the flight to Newark
[Music]
why are you doing this because no one
else will
leaders crazy visit you you don't know
me
in a place slam real fast so I know
there's been a lot of talk about the
next Xbox Xbox X which is kind of a
funny way to call it this is Sony that's
why it's ps4 you see that really crazy
vertical integration Sony wants your
money really bad so if you're thinking
about switching to Xbox for the next
iteration and you really want this game
you're probably just better off sticking
with the ps4 but this isn't going to
drop till 2018 so you'll actually
probably know what's going on with the
next spider-man movie before you get a
chance to play this like those are
talking about spider-man homecoming 2 or
whatever they're going to call it
spider-man prom those are talking about
that later this summer at Comic Con but
let me know in the comments what do you
guys think about this what do you think
about a big arkham style spider-man game
i feel like a lot of big triple-a games
are headed the direction of arkham
especially in this comic book universe
because there's way too many characters
to fit into a really linear game so this
open area gameplay where you can roam
around do side mission interact with
characters and really cool cinematic
ways this is what you want so when the
game gets a little bit closer to
dropping i'll actually give away a
couple of copies it's over come on let's
go miles so the thing here about Miles
Morales everyone's like oh my god he
said miles so that must be ganky that
doesn't mean that they're gonna kill
spider-man in this game so that miles
can take up the mantle he might even be
a playable character but they haven't
revealed that yet like they haven't said
oh you'll definitely be able to play as
mild as they wouldn't tease this if you
weren't going to be able to interact
with them in some meaningful way in the
game so there will be Miles Morales
ultimate spider-man content that's mixed
in with this congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner sword of the
evening please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for brand new Justice League and you can
click here and you can click here for
that big spider-man special from behind
the scenes
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight